I'm so excited for my guest tonight
viiay former Daily Show correspondent
you've also seen him on Modern Family
the movie The Hangover also one of my
favorite movies stepbrothers he's also
going to be in the upcoming movie 22
Jump Street jump Jump Street please give
it up for the hilarious Rob Riggle
everybody
good now have it you like it huh pretty
night night I'm not really but it looks
like the chair like the IKEA bed floor
you know they have the employee that
watches the beds this is the chair
she can't be falling asleep she got to
watch them bit yes just to be stiffened
a little yeah little uncomfortable like
a good church thank you thank you were
searching like like a it's a church and
again you can twins a lot of time you've
been in the house of God well P I attend
regularly do you yes really whatever I
like to mix it up you're just completely
conflicting ideologies a little temple
little Church got two parts of zigzag
lyrics exactly they get seventy percent
I mean the Jews of the of the book isn't
somebody with like oh oh baby man there
you are you ever just trying crack like
start with judges here's something like
huh yeah I'll just take my chance lip it
open well you know you do anything you
do you know you've pop it open and do
the older let me give this one a shot
and it's you know bring in your daughter
yeah or somebody because somebody dozers
yeah got some way our smited someone or
there's colorful language they'll be
like he took his manly and you're like
huh you look in the footnotes it's like
that means what it sounds like it means
I'm severed his weiner and fed it to
wild wild dog while don't know that they
call wild dogs a lot of everything the
dirty Virg exactly look at you I I
haven't seen you in a while it looks
real like a saber-toothed tiger yeah
yeah Bobby you've trimmed up yes I've
tried what did you do I literally just
have to everything I was eating you're
like I'm gonna lose weight butcher not
patsies
half of that chicken in the state it
used to be like a five minute walk Wow
now she's a girl that's it
but it's working it is work